Hi, my name's Adam Kocoloski with IBM Cloud
and I'm here to talk to you today about Apache  CouchDB,
a database we depend on extensively within the IBM Cloud,
and one powers a lot of innovative, modern cloud-native applications.
The first thing you'll notice about CouchDB is the way it is built of the web.
Users make HTTP requests to the database
and the database responds with JSON payloads.
And developers tend to find this to be a really natural fit
in this era of microservices applications
where all of your apps functionality is itself being decomposed
into these different web services.
The other critical features about the database though
are under the covers, so to speak.
The database has a very durable storage engine,
something that was built from the ground up
for this kind of modern world of variable cloud infrastructure,
it's a crash-friendly design that always knows how to pick itself up back up and keep on moving.
It's also very reliable system.
CouchDB was developed in a programming language called  Erlang
that hails from the telecommunications industry
and benefits from its decades of  experience
running production telephony switches.
And finally, couch is a noSQL database,
it's a non-relational database and
that means that it makes some trade-offs.
You have to think about how to model your data
in JSON document form
and you have to have a pretty good understanding of the kind of queries
you want to make of the database
so that you can design the right you know views and indexes
to support those queries.
But if you do, in exchange for that
you get scalability.
You get predictable, reliable performance of the application
as the data volume grows
and as the number of users of your application increase.
But really the killer feature about CouchDB
is its synchronization capabilities.
Let's say you started building your cloud application over here in U.S. West,
and you have decided that you need to add a disaster recovery site.
So, you can, at any point in time,
replicate the data from U.S. West over here to U.S. East.
And now you've got an always up-to-date copy of the data over here in this other cloud region.
But it doesn't stop there,
you can also choose to set up that replication in an active-active,
bidirectional fashion.
Now not only do you have another site for fault tolerance and high availability,
but you also have the ability to direct your users over on the East Coast
to the U. S. East region for lower latency.
But CouchDB doesn't stop there.
In fact, you can include any number of different other
databases in different locations
into a single replication mesh.
You could have on-premises systems,
you could have edge locations,
you could have databases running in other cloud providers.
And each of those is able to take
possibly a filtered subset of the data down from one of these regions,
make changes to it and push it back up.
That kind of flexibility is really without peer
in this world of cloud databases
and I think it's something that is particularly valuable in this hybrid cloud,
multicloud world in which we live today.
Thanks for watching this video.
If you have any questions, or comments please drop us a line.
If you enjoyed this content please "like" and subscribe.